heartbreak opens onto the sunrise for
even breaking his opening and I am
broken I'm open so see the love shine in
through my cracks
see the light shine out through me
my spirit takes journey my spirit takes
flight and I'm not running I am choosing
I know for homecoming that I want to go
with Greg and who you're gonna totally
I'm not gay
what do you mean you're not going if she
don't wanna go she'll have to go well
some reason he just doesn't like
anything I pick out for her anymore
you look beautiful maybe this isn't me
there's this new Women's Club up there
by the liquor store you haven't heard
anything about it
right and never even heard of it what'd
it say somebody liked you what if the
person is kind of like a friend but you
know they like you more than that
I told you I talked to a leaker
everything's fine did you ask no because
I don't have to
I don't want to face it back no joint is
turned into a damn man right I'm broken
I'm broken open breaking is freeing
broken is freedom I'm not broken I'm
free